غريب جدًا
كما لو كان في لحمك
مثل التمساح
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
أرخص من الهيروين،
ولهذا السبب يستخدمونه، إنه أمر
سيئ ولكن ما ستفعله
عندما تكون مدمنًا
على مادة الزيلازين فهي
تستمر في الأنسجة في ذلك
تستمر المنطقة في الموت حتى
تصل إلى العظم أو كما تعلم أو
يجب عليهم بتر جسم
أجنبي نستخدمه
في المواد الأفيونية الهيروين
والفنتانيل يسمى ناركان ولكن هذا ليس
فعالاً إذا تم مزجه مع الزيلازين
وبالتالي لن يؤدي ذلك بالضرورة إلى إحياء
شخص تناول مزيجًا من
الفنتانيل والزيلازين،
لذلك نستمر في رؤية المشكلة تتسع،
حسنًا،
من الصعب في الواقع تتبعها لأنها
ليست مادة خاضعة للرقابة، وحتى لو
وجدنا كمية كبيرة منها، فلن
نتمكن من محاكمة شخص ما بسبب ذلك
اجنبية
[موسيقى]